yeah when I see the Oscar sitting there
I'm like is this actually real
I need to slap myself am I still awake
am I dreaming do that again slap
yourself again I look at my the Oscar
and I slap myself am I still awake
I just want to say at the top though
that we've got our sign language
interpreter Justin here the reason is
because when you sign and speak at the
same time we call it simcom
simultaneously signing and speaking at
the same time that's like using two
different languages people should
realize that ASL has got its own syntax
its own structure so just a little
moment of Education that we have this
very talented interpreter here so that
Troy can get the pure ASL interpretation
of what I'm saying and then he can
respond back when you hear uh this
talented man tell us what choice sing
I get it thank you for explaining that
it's much more clear to communicate in a
Pure Life and if I were to simcom it
would be perpetuating the myth out there
and here in the hearing world that it's
so normal it's not we're trying to
normalize uh
so many things today I really want to
thank all of the wonderful deaf theater
stages where I was allowed and given the
opportunity to develop my craft as an
actor
thank you knowing you for 30 years and
acting with you in many many many
Productions we met in I think 1993 or
94. first thing we did was I think it
was 94. right Mice and Men we did
together
in all those years at deaf West Theater
we were struggling actors and then just
recently we did American buffalo for the
second time which is I think our
greatest accomplishment as a team
the overwhelming feeling I had from Coda
when I watched it Not only was your work
still and beautiful but what I
immediately thought of was the 30 years
before that you sleeping in your car
Troy you being an actor and I will say
this about you you have always thought
of yourself as a pure actor and that's
what I've always thought of you and if
it meant that you had to sleep in your
car or travel somewhere work for no
money you did it that word struggling
actor and there's thousands of them
right here in this in this city that are
talented just as talented as you are or
I am a real actors and they're not going
to get a break unless they keep on going
and that's the one thing I never stopped
working even if it was in theater the
same thing for you we worked together
and starved as actors on a theater stage
99 seat houses
I felt weird about 10 years ago there's
a lot of people that would come up to me
and say hey Troy why are you doing this
acting thing why do you keep on going I
said I'm fine they go where's your Oscar
I don't see you in any movies and so I
started to feel those insults and
criticism it was like maybe I should
become a teacher or maybe I should do
something but I was I was stubborn I was
persistent and I tried to find a way to
survive I had I started to think about
my finances and my daughter she's
graduating high school that was a bit
scary for me and I had to really change
my mindset to financially support my
family and so that required a lot of
sacrifice and there wasn't a lot of
money how were we going to save money I
communicated with my wife and I said hey
would it be all right if I stayed in the
theater dressing room in the backstage
because she understood that and and she
was an actor herself so she had this
understanding and I was so blessed to
have my wife's understanding and
collaboration
and so I would just be worrying about my
financial situation and how are we going
to pay the bills and how are we going to
buy groceries and so I washed cars I
mowed lawns I was helping in kitchens I
washed dishes
and we would do that so that I would try
and pay my wife back you know and I'd
give people free tickets to see the show
because I didn't have a way of thanking
people for helping us out that's all
real that's the that's all the real
that actors go through
well my advice for young children or
young deaf aspiring actors first of all
be prepared have a positive attitude and
be committed because they'll like you if
you have those three those three things
and they'll want to work with you again
and be reliable and be prepared because
so important to be prepared before you
arrive on set in rehearse with that
preparation and doing your homework and
memorizing your lines you know to have
your script with you you need to have
your hands free as a deaf actor to sign
and be able to improvise
and so if you rehearse at home then they
will trust you and see that you're
reliable and that you can go through
this process and you'll come to mind if
they like working with you not only in
acting just in any profession in general
in the real world right work with as
many people as you can and they will
remember you I would tell young Paul and
Young Troy look the universe is here for
you your heart is in the right place
keep doing what you're doing and so you
know I mean it's it's easy for me to say
that now but that's what makes your
successes
all the more glorious
and what could be more glorious than
coming all this way and getting an
Academy Award or even a nomination I
don't know if I told you this story
troyo when I was a little boy in the 50s
there was no closed captioning there
were no technology for deaf people in
1956 1956 Elvis came out with a movie
Elvis Elvis
oh Elvis right yeah that's good they're
good enough
and my mother took me to see that movie
but I didn't know I didn't know that
we'd be sitting in the theater watching
a Love Me Tender and I thought oh I
have to interpret this whole damn movie
for her so I'm like there's the movie
and I'm like you know interpreting from
my mom I was doing Elvis his brother the
lover the horse all this and my
mother loved it you know and on the way
home we were like so connected uh
because we shared this uh theatrical
experience I didn't know it then but
years later when I discovered the acting
Department in my University that I was
going to after Vietnam I opened up the
door of a theater and I saw these people
on stage talking to a chair
doing an acting exercise and I thought
to myself
acting as a craft
I could do this
so then it started
I remember when I was young
I had never seen any films with closed
captioning but I loved visual films like
Godzilla I loved Godzilla the original
Japanese Godzilla because it was fun and
he was destroying these cities and there
was all this combat he was breathing
fire and I thought oh wow I didn't need
closed captioning for that and then I'd
go through the channels looking for some
type of visual action and I see a lot of
Talking Heads which is quite boring or
maybe a musical but I was most excited
about a cartoon called Tom and Jerry and
it was an amazing visual storytelling
without dialogue there was fight scenes
there was Chase scenes and so on with
cat and mouse and it was fascinating to
me as a young deaf boy and I would
memorize these episodes and I would tell
the story the next morning on the school
bus during our commute to the school for
the deaf and many of these deaf kids
didn't have a TV at that time and so I
would tell them what I saw the previous
day and these kids were fascinated I saw
the glow in their eyes and they really
enjoyed my storytelling and that's where
my spark began when I saw these kids
eyes light up and sometimes I like pass
over to another kid and they'd say hey I
want to try yeah I enjoyed watching them
too and we'd compare our language I'd
say hey I really like that sign and like
eyes bulging out
and I said hey I'm going to use your
sign for that and so the point was is we
fed off each other's creative language
and that's how we killed these hours of
commute time and so that's where my
spark for acting began
I see you've made your choice right
and I sincerely hope
that it brings you happiness Reuben for
me
being accepted or being offered the
chance to be in the academy was a
validation of all the work that I've
been doing when it happened to you the
year after I was thrilled to death
because you deserve it so much
it's funny when that happened and I saw
you were a nominee I was thrilled and I
told myself wow I feel so proud because
finally you know I've known how hard
you've worked through the years and I
felt like you really deserved it and I
was so thrilled to have been a part of
award season to be recognized and to
share this experience and journey with
you because you have such great talent
and we've worked together for 30 years
and it's been amazing and I felt like I
wasn't alone and I was so glad to know
more nominees personally and hopefully
we'll work together again I've seen what
deaf people have gone through I've seen
what codas have gone through including
my daughters and that's why I dedicated
my oscar to the deaf Community the coda
community and the disabled Community
because I really felt like they deserved
it because I've seen everything they've
done I just want to say congratulations
on all your success you did you really
deserve it you did a great job it's been
amazing to have this conversation with
you and that we are both continually
motivated even though we knew how tough
it was we just needed to work it was
truly amazing and this is just a small
world you know we were just it's like a
hair in my beard right and that equaled
the opportunities of us that we had was
just like one individual hair that one
opportunity how profound is that you're
deep you're deep well here's the more
and more success
I'm proud of you and my brother you're
my brother
[Music]
oh